[Music]
you are watching the press preview
a first look at what's on the front
pages as they arrive
in the next half hour we'll see what's
making the headlines with polly mckenzie
chief executive of the demos think tank
and pr consultant alex dean so
let's see what's on some of those front
pages for you now well the ft leads on
the tory's shock by-election defeat in
cheshire and amisham
with conservative mps blaming it on
toxic planning reforms
that story also makes the front of the
guardian as senior conservatives are
reportedly
warning the prime minister that a swathe
of blue wall seats across the south of
england could be at risk
the yorkshire post reports that northern
political leaders are urging the prime
minister to address a huge gulf
between his leveling up ambitions and
reality
and so we're joined tonight by polly
mckenzie and alex
dean good evening to you both um let's
start off first of all with the guardian
just first we'll have to say that
actually
the papers aren't coming in because
obviously because of the football
uh much delayed because if they want to
get that story
into the editions but the ones that we
have got in will take viewers through
those so we start with the guardian
and uh their headline their tour is
fearing a blue wall seats at risk
after lib dem victory are they really
in fear alex would you say
when you lose a seat like this with a 16
000
vote majority you should take note of
this and i think people trying to write
off a defeat and suggest that it's
you know down purely to local factors or
turnout was down 20 000 which is
true these are excuses you do have to
look at this
seriously but i i must say i mean you
know
governments normally lose by elections
and that's of late not being the case
but that's absolutely the historical
norm
again these are excuses i don't think
it's a good result for anyone to be
honest i mean
plainly it's not a good result for the
conservative party it's a disastrous
result for the labour party their worst
by-election result ever now has some
muttering about
leadership challenge and i don't think
it's a good way for the lib dems to win
an election either campaigning against a
progressive
liberal policy of more house building
and more homes for younger
and people less well-off people so i
think in the medium term it's bad for
them too it's a plague upon all their
houses
uh by election for me isn't isn't
winning the the the a
is there a bad way to win alex i think
it's a really grotty way to win
oh polly what what say you
uh well i mean all the political parties
end up being pretty ruthless when it
comes to ground campaigning i i once
stood
for council election and leaflets went
out saying that i had stolen a council
house
which was i'd like to stress not true um
uh
the liberal democrats have often been
accused of sort of saying one thing one
place saying anything to get elected
but they've also gone on the receiving
end of vicious attacks by
the other parties about being kind of
soft on
crime or all sorts of things you know
um so in the end it is about winning
it's a it's a surprising
and yet impressive victory for the
liberal democrats but i do
share alex's concern about
just the skepticism about planning
reform about house building
that is held across older people across
home owners and traditionally the
conservative party has been the
supporters the champions
of those people against the interests of
renters
of people who don't own their home they
have
consistent new policies that are about
basically the housing market more
propping up
our kind of uh ponzi scheme house price
inflation
and liberalizing that is one of the best
things i think that this government is
doing
and i remain one of the i think of hs2
so uh i do share some of the sadness
about
what the you know that the people of
cheshire have in part voted for which is
to just shut down reform growth
and house building uh but i think there
is more to it than that you know there's
also just the question of
whether the conservatives can hold
together this comp
coalition or their new voters in the
north one of the fascinating things was
liberal democrats
sort of being there nobody talks about
us we've been left behind narrative
which the conservatives have played so
effectively in the north
back at those voters who hear the
conservatives talk
north all the time and a bit like hello
you've gotten about me
alex you wanted to come in there well i
was just going to say are you
this is the conservative party's most
liberal policy
the housing policy that the government
has and it's for the lib dems to win an
election
opposing that rather than taking a no
pun intended more constructive approach
on it
i think does mean that it's rather
difficult for um
davey i think he may live to regret that
silly photo stunt knocking down a blue
wall with his yellow hammer
i think if you can't afford to buy a
home and a gleeful lib dem leader who
gets elected
with the vivid symbolism of him bashing
down a wall
uh might come back to haunt him but i
also think i mean
bear in mind they support that policy
nationally but oppose it locally
so you know to polly saying sometimes
the liberal democrats are accused of
saying
something one one level and then another
thing at another level
they did in this election but they also
support hs2
nationally which is apparently a
progressive and green uh policy which
they endorse at the national stage
but absolutely oppose and say is
terrible and notorious sell out
at the local level so it's a very bad
way i think to win an election that's
why i use the term that i use that you
uh were surprised by dealing because i
do think it's a bad way to go out and
winning a by-election but fair dues to
polly if you think the only thing if the
only thing that
matters really is winning it is no doubt
an impressive
uh victory and a big turnaround in what
was a safe tourist seat
and polly how much um credence is there
to to the view that
it really was a protest vote
particularly in terms of
of hs2
all of these things are complicated but
just to be clear i think i agreed with
alex
about the importance of liberal planning
reform i'm a massive fan of house
building
i remember when i worked in government
writing endless papers trying to get us
up to
house building numbers of 300 000 which
now is conservative policy and i
absolutely welcome i'm not sure about
this
uh the the the supporting it nationally
point
i remember at davey i think in his first
pmq's criticizing the planning policies
it was already going to be difficult to
get those planning policies
through parliament uh there was already
talk of a conservative rebellion from
the shire seats against uh the
algorithmic
decision-making around how many homes
ought to be built
because if you build a lot of homes
prices
will inevitably law of economics supply
and demand prices will stop rising or
they
even fall a tiny bit so that wages can
catch up and wouldn't that be glorious
for the country but of course not for
homeowners and so it was controversial
already
i think the chance of those reforms
getting through now
have been struck an enormous blow i
think it's i think it's really sad
let's move on to the ft alex uh
and they're really coming from the point
of view that the the reforms are
toxic they're looking at it through that
sort of a
prism um and also in the ft um
saying that the blue wall is vulnerable
yeah and this is the part of the
response we've seen from some
people briefing the media from within
government that the planning reforms
that the government has proposed are to
blame
or at least an inability to properly
explain them and put them
well to the electorate you will find
after every election
that a political party says we have
brilliant policies we just didn't
explain them very well if only our comms
had been better
then we would have won this election and
that's normally
what said even after you've put to the
electorate something that the
electorate plainly really hated and
you've gone backwards
like the so-called dementia tax that the
conservative party
uh offered to uh the electorate or you
know the
the tax rising hike um agenda
of the 1970s and 80s under labor
um normally people say well it's just we
didn't communicate it well enough
but i think this goes a bit further i
think polly is right i think that
the policy itself is probably in
jeopardy that may seem to be a
remarkable thing after a single
by-election
but there will be many people sitting in
seats that are a bit like cheshire and
american
where they the real face the real threat
they face the number two
party is the liberal democrats and they
will think to themselves well if they
can happen there with a 16 000 vote
majority
it can happen in my patch too and i
think the other thing i think is worth
bearing in mind with that
is who it squeezes out because that
you've got labour party increasingly
being
squeezed out by the conservatives in the
north and in the labour party being
squeezed out increasingly
in the south by the liberal democrats
and other leftist parties
and so on the big issues of the day now
some of the arguments are being had
not between starmer and johnson the big
debates of the day being had between the
liberal democrats and the conservative
party
that's a very ugly place for the labour
party the opposition to be in
polly is it a a blip in in terms of the
liberal democrats because you know many
people commentators have been saying
that ed davey has been speaking up this
this victory
um it's not the end of conservatism
in in areas as we've seen in amisham and
it's he hasn't broken any blue wall and
as alex was saying earlier that he might
come to regret that
that stunt with his yellow hammer
i i don't i don't think that's true i
mean it
most political photo ops and stunts are
kind of cringy and embarrassing and this
was uh
no exception but um i think
the challenge for the liberal democrats
is what is their political strategy
within the party within the uh the
policy framework that they vote through
democratically
they're very progressive i saw you know
liberal democratic activists talking
about how
if this uh election was translated to
everywhere they'd have a majority
wouldn't that be amazing because then
they'd be able to uh abolish welfare
sanctions
introduce universal basic income have
massive redistribution
um and all sorts of things that actually
would be
probably not what the people of chesham
and amisham have voted for
and yet there is clearly a group of
people
the more affluent uh people a small c
conservative in these tourist shires in
you know south west london where ed
davey holds his own seat
for whom you know the the conservative
support is soft and it's partly soft
because the conservatives have gone
chasing after votes in the north and
have gone for a more
culturally conservative approach
so um there's this then choice for the
liberal democrats do you
pursue this uh the the radical agenda of
radical redistribution
uh urgent kind of climate emergency
overhaul of absolutely everything you
look at or do you go for a socially
conservative
more affluent uh environmental kind of
vote in those
uh traditionally tory shires it it's
quite hard to be both of those things at
the same time
with a sort of carbonite style policy
that you're selling to the the wealthy
um
more old elderly even voters of cheshire
and amisham and and other constituencies
they might be able to do it you know but
it it's not
as the necessarily anti-poverty party
let's quickly move on to the um
yorkshire post and they're reporting on
a report by uh sheffield
academics in which the the government
they're saying the government's current
policies to tackle regional inequalities
offer funding that mostly isn't new is
often short-term and looks likely to be
scattered widely across the country alex
well the conservative party plainly has
to live up to the promise it made to
voters in the north when our prime
minister memorably asked them to lend
him their vote
and in cease after seat they did but i
do think there's a connection between
these
two areas of conversation obviously uh
between
the two regarded as safe conservative
seats in the south which some now allege
have been taken for granted
and the new seats in the north which the
conservative party has made
real inroads in and one of the
connections that we haven't discussed
yet
is the quality of campaigning because it
is obvious in
the north that some of the gains have
been made not just in
mpc it's been in merrell seats too like
ben hatchins there's some of the games
been made by just really good
campaigning
by people who are super um effective on
the ground and running
good campaigns and knocking on doors
well and with good effective messages
and to be clear one possibility out of
cheshire and american
is that the lib dems just campaigned
better than the tories so they were
there in bigger numbers is that they
were there
more persuasively they were there for
longer every day
and i was there for a couple of days uh
doing my best and it was obvious that
the lib dems had swamped that seat
had been up and down it and knocking on
every door and leafleting everybody with
the kinds of news that they wanted to
hear
well it may just be that the tories have
been better at campaigning in the north
of late and the lib dems have been a bit
better in campaigning in
leafy hitherto tory seats okay alex and
polly for the moment
thank you do stay with us much more
coming up
shortly
[Music]
i witnessed how the catalan fight for
independence split
families it was from this chamber that
carlos putimon declared
independence in october
i come here because i want to show other
people what happened
i'm michelle clifford and i'm skye's
europe correspondent
it's not the aim of the smugglers to
actually get people to uk shores
but simply into british waters
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
there are real concerns here now about
whether the health system
will be able to cope president macron
has spoken in defense of
freedom of expression saying france
won't give up its caricatures and
drawings
made by people who dare to challenge
afternoon mr barnier
how are you i have no time for any
[Music]
politics
[Music]
anger about wider social and economic
problems in this nation
we are on the verge of fascism and we
have a country to use
i'm adam parsons i'm skye's europe
correspondent based here in brussels
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
sun
[Applause]
hello or like we say in my language is
lay
i am tauntive the founder and the ceo of
renewables in africa this picture
changed my whole career
and my whole life our mission is simple
is to bring back power to africa
and our being is to turn the dark
continent that i saw in 2008
into a brighter and prosperous one by
2040.
[Applause]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me paulie mckenzie chief
executive of the demos think tank and pr
consultant
alex dean welcome back to both of you
and i said earlier that we were waiting
for papers to come in because of the
football they are coming in gradually
uh so let's start with one that's uh
covering the the football and that's the
sun
england and scotland can't be separated
uh was it an anti-climax for either view
alex start with you first yeah oh look
whenever one expresses an opinion you'll
immediately be
asked on social media could you do any
better so for the avoidance of doubt
no i couldn't but god it was dull as
[ __ ] water
and the light said the last 10 minutes
it just felt like it would feel like
agony watching
you know english hopes um i mean high
hopes sort of dissipate into
flaccid inactivity but i think this is a
brilliant headline
england and scotland can't be separated
you know which is what you say when
someone gets a draw but also a very
smart line about the union
bravo the sun i don't know if they have
much time to think about it because
nobody expected it to be a draw
but great headline polly what did you
make of it
did you see any of the game yeah yeah i
watched it with my kids
for the first time they stayed up late
my seven-year-old son just kept saying
what's the score what's the score
you know like are we there yet i just
didn't understand why it was still
zero zero he's like they've been playing
for 73 minutes and no one
scored so i think i
i've sort of had some something of his
sense of torpor and boredom but i did
eat a lot of
crisps so you know okay that was alps oh
there's always an upside isn't there
um very quickly let's just finish off on
uh this story in the ft
and this is um brussels uh losing out in
this battle with
with astr zenico not got much time left
but uh just run us through
alex so remarkably brussels thought it
would be a smart idea to try to go to
law
against astrazeneca one of the companies
that's just delivered us
a um a vaccine to save millions of lives
i'm sure somewhere
in the um network there are clients
somewhere of businesses i do business
with so
declaration i'm sure there's although i
don't work with them someone will
but my god it's still even from my
perspective felt like that
episode uh where is that one nazi turns
to another and says are we the baddies
and what do they think they were doing
suing astrazeneca
on a basis of a contract that said we'll
make to our best endeavors to get
vaccines to you well they
lo and behold they got their bottoms
handed to them in court
they should think very carefully about
doing it again it seemed to me to be an
act of desperation from the eu
unwilling to admit that they negotiated
very badly over con
contracts for vaccines they instead
resorted to lashing out
well as bullies often find out it didn't
work out oh
harsh words alex and polly for the
moment thank you much more coming up
at 11 for the meantime thank you very
much